Despite what you might be thinking,
these two circles are not equal.
I repeat.
These two circles are not equal.
One is in fact larger than the other.
What I need you to do is determine which
one that is,
so please raise your hand if you believe
the blue circle is larger than the red.
All right,
please raise your hand if you believe
the red circle is larger than the blue.
Right?
Very good.
Now,
before I said anything about these two
circles,
what was your first instinct?
Equal,
right?
Because they look equal and the reason
why they look equal,
it's pleasant back.
They are equal.
These circles are identical.
Yet I got just about every one of you to
raise your hand and say that they're
not.
So what did we learn?
That you can be manipulated like that to
believe in something that goes against
your natural instincts.
Just just imagine.
Just imagine as a child,
you're taught that the blue circle is
larger than the red.
If you say it enough times,
you convince yourself.
That's the truth.
If you're told the lie enough times,
it becomes part of your reality and if
enough people are taught that lie that
the blue circle is larger than the red,
well now it becomes part of the culture
and if that culture then passes that
misinformation along to the next
generation now become a tradition and we
have to remember is that just because we
have a tradition doesn't mean it's
morally acceptable.
Tradition and morality are not always
the same,
so the traditions we have today doesn't
necessarily mean that morally
acceptable,
and as we evolve as a culture,
so do our traditions.
Now the matrix is a story.
It's a story when told enough times to
enough people,
it becomes part of that culture.
It becomes the tradition and this story
is being told over and over every day.
In fact,
if you believe the image on the carton
is where you're getting your milk from,
you're deceiving yourself.
This is a fantasy.
It only exists in your head.
It's a blue pill fed to you by the
industry to get you to buy their
product.
This is the Matrix,
the lie we tell ourselves about where
our food is coming from.
The reality is far more disturbing.
Ninety to 95 percent of the milk,
the meat
and the eggs that we consume in the
United States are coming from these
conditions,
and this is called factory farming.
This is what you take thousands of hens,
pigs and cows.
You can find them into warehouses is
that every year in the United States,
10 billion,
10 billion cows,
pigs and chickens are being slaughtered
for food.
So what that works out to be is at every
second in the United States,
300 animals are killed just like that.
So 300,
600,
900,
1200.
By the time I'm done talking to the,
it'll be over a million animals that
have been slaughtered and most of us
don't even blink it not.
How is it possible that in United States
of America we can kill?
We can slot it 300 animals every second
and not question that because of the
story we've been told,
the story justifies the action.
If you say it enough times,
you actually convince yourself.
That's the truth.
How many of you were taught as a child,
you need to eat meat to get protein.
I knew I was.
How many of you were taught you need to
drink cow's milk to get strong bones?
Not Dog?
No.
Not Chimpanzee.
Email.
Not Elephant Mill.
Not Rhino.
Milk.
Not Hippo milk.
Not Tiger milk.
Not Lion.
They'll not giraffe milk.
Not Elephant Milk.
Did I say that already?
I think you get the point.
Not even our own mother's milk,
but we need to drink cow's milk to get
strong bones.
The absurdity of drinking the milk from
any other species and any other being
besides her own mother.
When it said enough times loses its
absurdness.